God can use this to get our attention as
the world not just a nation but the
world to look to him and to put our
faith and trust in Him on March 20th
Italy had 47,000 kovat 19 cases with
over 4,000 deaths more than half of
those deaths came from the Lombardi
region where the town of cremona is
located just outside of Milan that's the
day Samaritan's Purse came to Cremona
Samaritan's Purse is a
non-denominational evangelical Christian
organization providing spiritual and
physical aid to hurting people
around the world in 36 hours Samaritan's
Purse
had a 68 bed field hospital set up in
the Cremona hospital parking lot aiding
the coronavirus relief then come April
1st they also set up a field hospital in
the middle of Central Park in New York
City the epicenter of the Cova 19
outbreak in the United States my guest
today is Franklin Graham president and
CEO of Samaritan's Purse and the son of
world famous evangelical Billy Graham
who's considered to be one of the most
influential Christian leaders of all
time carrying on that legacy Franklin
has become a Christian leader in his own
right meeting privately with five US
presidents and world leaders from Europe
Africa Asia and Latin America as well as
responding to global crises in over 100
countries through Samaritan's Purse
he's also the president and CEO of the
Billy Graham Evangelistic sociation on
this Easter Sunday we talk about the
inspiring stories of hope from the
corona virus pandemic Franklin's
thoughts on how the Trump presidency has
been going his father's legacy and the
age-old question of why bad things
happen to good people
[Music]
Franklin Graham thanks so much for
stopping by the Ben Shapiro show Sunday
special so I have a lot I want to get to
with you discuss your father's legacy
and where you stand on President Trump
will talk politics but obviously we have
to start with situation with regard to
coronavirus first of all how's your
family dealing with with all of this I
hope that you're doing okay we're all
doing fine we're just out doing the work
God has called us to Ben we don't slow
down we just keep going forward well I
definitely appreciate your work and when
we get to that in just a second I want
to ask you that there are a lot of
religious people in the United States
who right now are deeply troubled by all
of the calls by state and local
governments to shut down churches and
their people who work with me here at
des Lee Weyer who have been upset that
the government has deemed churches
non-essential for purposes of shutting
them down and shutting down mass
gatherings right now you know as a
religious person what's your perspective
on the government telling people to stay
home from church what do you think
Christians ought to do I mean we're
approaching Easter season well first of
all I think we need to obey those that
are authority that's what the Bible
teaches and so I think it's very
important that we do that the churches
are not shut down I think more people
are attending online services than they
did when you were meeting in person
there's something about this virus that
has put fear and anxiety in people's
hearts so I think just more people are
online and they're there they're
participating that way so the church
needs to continue to be the church but I
just would encourage pastors across the
country to obey those that are nathie
and I think that's what the
congregations would expect us to do yeah
I mean as an Orthodox Jew myself I've
been encouraging people to to stay home
from synagogue which has been tall order
in some sectors and it seems to me that
actually is it's a fairly large-scale
desecration of God's name when there's
video and pictures of people going on
mass - to religious institutions in
violation of government edicts that are
specifically designed to prevent massive
loss of life you know and we do have to
be careful being because this is a very
infectious and it's a deadly virus
especially those that have underlying
health issues this could be a death
sentence and so we just have to be
extremely careful but I don't think that
should we should stop doing the work
that
God has called us to do but we do need
to be careful I think practicing social
distancing these types of things is wise
of course it's Samaritan's Purse we're
at work some of my people are working
from home others still come to the
essential people have to come to the
office so we're still working when we're
not we haven't missed anything we just
have to work a little differently than
we're used to doing so let's talk about
some of the things that Samaritan's
Purse is doing around the around the
country and around the globe in order to
combat kornel virus it really is an
amazing organization what you guys have
been doing in order to help people is
truly incredible what are some of the
things that Samaritan's Purse has been
doing not only in the United States but
abroad well three weeks ago we sent a
emergency field hospital to Cremona and
northern Italy outside of Milan about 50
miles of Milan this is the epicenter for
the corona virus in Italy and we've got
a 68 bed filled hospital we're working
in conjunction with a local hospital but
we have about 70 personnel there right
now that are these are doctors and
nurses and technicians that are working
in that hospital trying to save life in
northern Italy and that that is a very
important place for us to be because the
Italians were not getting any assistance
from anybody in the world and I think
when we showed up it gave them it gave
them a ray of hope that somebody is
listening somebody cares and they're
here helping us and so of course as a
Christian organization Ben we always
feel that we should respond in Jesus
name that's what we do and as Christians
we want people to know that God loves
them that God hasn't forgotten them he
has it turned his back on them and then
just last week we got a call from New
York City asking if we would be willing
to put a hospital there and we've always
keep two hospitals in in stock in our
warehouse our these are the same
hospitals at the US military basically
the same that the US military uses we
have military former military doctors
that work for so we go to the same
vendors and we buy the same hospitals
that the US military does we make them a
little different for our applications
but they have operated
they have intensive care units they have
laboratory they were able to do the
sterilization so everything that a
hospital would do how we can do it but
for the coronavirus says a full
respiratory so we don't need operating
theaters for the respiratory care so we
we mix it up a little bit differently
and we bring in of course more
ventilators than you would normally and
that's what we've got set up into corona
and then now in New York City or when
they were asked us last week how are we
set up we set a team up there over the
weekend we were given a central park
right across from Mount Sinai Hospital
East Meadows it's a 98th and Fifth
Avenue and so we've set up and actually
today I mean the last three days we've
been putting the hospital together today
we received our first patients that they
believe that we'll be full maybe before
the end of this day I don't know but
we're there to serve the people of New
York anyone who comes who doesn't matter
who they are being we're going to help
them we're going to love them we're
going to care for them and we're going
to give them the best medical care that
we possibly can we're not going to give
anything less than best I read an
article maybe you read it too about a
person there in New York who lost a
loved one in the hospital and this and
the wife was distraught because she
could not be in the hospital with her
husband as he died and so she said he
died alone and how sad and how much
remorse she had that her husband died
alone well I don't I hope and pray no
one dies in our hospital but if they do
I can promise you bin they're not gonna
die alone our doctors and nurses will
surround them we pray inform holding
hold in their hand till they take the
last breath and I just want of all
relatives to know if they come to our
Hospital we'll take care of them and
we're gonna show them compassion and
love the same that the Lord Jesus Christ
would I mean I'm one of the things that
that's amazed me is not only the good
work that you guys are doing but but
also some of the reactions that I could
work so naturally Twitter which is just
a repository of all stupidity and known
to man that there there's a bit of an
issue today and over the last few days
about Samaritan's Purse being behind the
hospital people in New York shocked to
learn some some radicals in New York
shocks one that Samaritan's Purse is a
Christian organization
that has a Christian view of particular
biblical edicts including the fact that
Samaritan's Purse believes that
homosexual activity is a sin and somehow
they were suggesting that this
invalidates Samaritan's Purse doing
their work in new york i just love for
you to clarify that sinners purse is not
in fact telling people who are gay
lesbian transgender they can't show up
to the hospital if they have coronavirus
know everybody's welcome and if a gay or
transgender person show up the hospital
would show them the same love and
compassion and give them the same
world-class health care that we give to
anybody else that comes but we are
Christians where we are not equal
opportunity employer
enough we don't do that the the the
doctors and nurses are we're all
Christians and what motivates us is our
is our faith in Jesus Christ and that's
what we have in common and that's the
that's what makes us that's what makes
us go forward and so we use that
compassion and that love and that
concern that Christ showed for people
how we use that to show the people that
come to us so for anybody I didn't
matter who you are we're going to treat
you the same and we do not discriminate
as a relates to the people that we help
and we've been doing this been for 50
years
Samaritan's Purse is 50 years old this
year and there has never been an
accusation that we that we refused
helped anybody because they do not
believe the same way we believe we just
don't do that well Franklin I want to I
want to ask you about sort of the lack
of tolerance for people who disagree
with you with with many Christians the
sumerians person just one second but
before we get to that I want to take a
moment to give a shout out to all our
advertising partners who help make this
show possible we are super grateful that
they decide to work with us and we
definitely appreciate our listeners
going out and patronizing our sponsors
and keeping all of this going really
appreciate both our listeners and our
advertisers we're all trying to get
through this together you me my shows
advertising partners so let's stick
together and get through this thing
there are things we each look back on
and think to ourselves how did I get it
so wrong it might be wearing multiple
polo shirts or booking that trip to the
fire festival or dating that one person
at one time you know the person I'm
talking about well we're always gonna
get things wrong hell I hired Michael
moles that's just life but there are
also things we can get right like
shopping for life insurance and that's
where policy genius comes in policy
genius makes finding
right life insurance a breeze in minutes
you can compare quotes from the top
insurers and find your best price it
could say 1500 bucks or more a year by
using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape for free and
policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they can also help you
find the right home and auto insurance
disability insurance so even if you look
back on the days when you hired a Yale
grad and thought this will be great and
it turns out he was a completely useless
piece of well forget that go over to
policy genius right now find your best
price apply a policy genius calm get the
life insurance you need we all get
things wrong from time to time but we
can get life insurance right with policy
genius check them out at policy genius
com
so Franklin I don't talk about the lack
of tolerance that seems to exist on one
side of the aisle so you mentioned
Samaritan's Purse is a Christian
organization that it has its viewpoint
on on Biblical sin and that that
viewpoint hasn't changed and that it has
obviously very Christian views this has
led to a radical amount of intolerance
from the other side of the aisle which
suggests that in certain situations you
should be shut down I noticed that there
was a story that prior to all of this
you had a book to our plan in the UK and
that you had a bunch of sites shut down
for the book tour specifically because
you are a quote-unquote discriminatory
what seems to be amazing to me is that
there are a lot of people who seem to
care very deeply about what you think of
them when the last I checked there is no
need to you are not a person who is
actually legislating morality you're not
a member of the government you are just
running a private organization you're
entitled to your religious viewpoints
well why do you think it is that there's
so much blowback whenever Samaritan's
Purse does something publicly whenever
you do something publicly based on your
view of biblical sin well I think it's
the blowback is it really so much
against me I think it's against God the
the view that I have is what the Bible
teaches and the Bible teaches that
marriage is between a man and a woman
that's that's what I believe and so I
hold to my religious beliefs
I don't compromise those I'm not going
to change them that's just what the
Bible teaches and so that's what I
believe and I again for the gay
community out there I love them and care
for them I I I want them to know the
truth
I want them to know what God says and I
want them to know what his his his word
has to say if because it's important
that we live our life in accordance to
his word
so I don't I don't condemn anybody God
is the one who condemns we're all gonna
have to stand before God one day give an
account to him for how we've lived our
lives and so I just want to warn people
I want people to know the truth but I
certainly do not condemn anybody and I'm
willing to help each and every person
that comes across my path and life
that's that's Who I am and that's what I
do so I want to talk a little bit more
about some of the good actions that
you've been taking you fared the Billy
Graham Rapid Response Team he talked a
little bit about the role of the team in
the midst of this crisis and what
they've been doing there these are
chaplains been and this came as a result
of 9/11 I was asked by Rudy Giuliani the
mayor at that time to come to a prayer
vigil at the pile the fire trucks still
had the the water poured on the pile you
can still smell the stench of the
rotting bodies and the smoke coming up
out of the pile and to me it minded me a
little bit maybe what hell would be like
it was a terrible scene and they stopped
everything for a few minutes to have a
prayer vigil and I realized while I was
in New York that there were not enough
pastors doctors chaplains people who
could pray with with those that were
suffering you had 3,000 some people they
died that day and and there's just not
enough people to deal with the grief
that New York was going through there
were not enough churches or synagogues
to hold the funeral services some
churches were holding five six one that
actually did ten in one day I don't know
how they did it but the funeral services
so it is incredible amount of grief and
there just weren't enough enough pastors
there and we put together a team of
chaplains and Ben went up there and just
went out to Chelsea Piers where they had
they makeshift memorial people were
there putting pictures and flowers and
we just started talking to people and
praying with people then we went to the
hospitals people standing outside
looking for a loved one
started praying with them and we had a
tremendous ministry but we went down to
the pile and we wanted to go have prayer
with the first responders nope you can't
come in you're not credentialed and a
credential how'd you get credentialed
what one of our chaplains was an FBI
chaplain I had no clue that they FBI had
chaplains and he had a badge FBI so he
showed that to the guard at the gate is
this credential good enough oh yes you
can come in and after that I thought
okay we need to find out how we can get
credentialed and we did the training
with Homeland Security through FEMA and
so forth got all they just went through
all the boxes checked all the hoops and
now we have hundreds we have over a
thousand chaplains here in the United
States that have been credentialed that
have had special training for crisis
situations like we're facing right now
so in New York we've got chaplains with
us at alongside our doctors and nurses
that are willing to pray with people
that want it we don't force somebody to
listen to a prayer but if somebody said
would you please pray for me absolutely
we're right there and we believe that
prayer is a part of what we do a very
important part as our doctors and nurses
are trying to save life but to have
chaplains praying for the doctors and
nurses and then to pray for the patients
is very important so we've got chaplains
there with us and so our work is of
course it's a spiritual work it's not
just physical but as spiritual as well
let's talk for a second about where this
particular crisis stacks up next to
other crises so obviously been doing
this for quite a while and you've dealt
with a number of crises not only in the
United States but abroad
how does Cova 19 stack up against the
other crises that you've seen in your
tenure there's never been a crisis like
this in my lifetime this is changed the
whole world the whole world then is on
lockdown
every country in the world is right now
locked down and it's frightening no
question about it there's something
that's it's a tsunami a virus that has
swept the globe and we don't know the
the answers to this we don't we don't
have an antidote we don't have the
vaccine
and the the fear that is in people's
hearts is incredible and
I just as a Christian I don't fear I'm
not worried about what's going to happen
tomorrow I gave my life
did Jesus Christ when I was 22 years old
when I confessed my sin and I asked
Christ to come into my heart and that
night God forgave me not because I'm a
good guy I'm not I'm a sinner but I
confessed my sin
and turn from those sins I invited Jesus
Christ to live in my life and I don't
fear being what what's before me I don't
I don't fear that if if God wants my
life to end today so bid my life is in
his hands I gave it to him he can take
me spin me use me however he wants me
and but the world right now is gripped
in fear and I've never seen anything
like it it's it is a not only there's an
a pandemic but it's a it's a worldwide
crisis we've never seen this in my
lifetime and you mentioned your own sort
of journey to faith in your faith
experience in 22 what prompted you to
move toward conversion to Christianity
or embrace of Christianity in in your
early twenties well of course now I grew
up as in a Christian home right my
father of course and evangelist my
mother grew up in a missionary family in
China and so when we went to church
every every Sunday we were involved in
the church we did those types of things
but your parents cannot choose Jesus
Christ for you and doesn't matter how
much they love me that was a choice I
had to make and I was 22 and I think Ben
I just got to the point in my life where
I was sick and tired of just being sick
and tired
you could go to parties you could date
you could do things you could have fun
but at the the next day you wake up
there would be an emptiness in your life
and you realize that you're you were
searching for something but you didn't
know what you're searching for and there
was this overwhelming emptiness and what
night I just got on my knees I said God
I've sinned and I'm sorry forgive me I
believe Jesus Christ is your son I
believe that he took my sins to the
cross that he died on that cross he was
buried for my sins and that you raised
him to life and I would like to invite
him
to come into my heart into my life and
if he could just take the pieces of my
life and put it together and make sense
of it you can have it I prayed that
prayer been in a minute and that night
God forgave Franklin Graham I'm I'm
still a sinner but I've been forgiven
Ben and I know that one day when I stand
before God he will welcome me because
not because of what I did but because of
what Jesus Christ did on my behalf when
he took my sins and died in my place and
I accepted that by faith the Bible says
by grace are we saved through faith it's
not of works lest any man should boast
if you could work for your salvation
people would brag about it's just part
of human nature you know let me tell you
what I had to pay let me tell you what I
had to do but when you come to God it's
by His grace and it's through faith and
there's nothing else let's talk about
the fact that Easter is obviously about
to be upon us
it's the Passover season in the Jewish
community it's it's a holy time of year
for for Jews and Christians alike it's
also the roughest time I've ever seen in
my lifetime and that that holds true for
Christians Jews and everybody else you
know the fact is there gonna be a lot of
people suffering going into Eastern a
lot of people suffering during during
the Passover season what what do you
think people should be meditating on and
thinking about during during the Easter
season well first of all there's there's
no community that has probably suffered
more in modern history than the Jewish
community and that they know what pain
and sorrow and they know what suffering
is all about and this this Easter season
much of the world is experiencing pain
and saw like they've never seen before
the the estimates for the people that
may die in this country are staggering
and we know that in the months ahead
it's going to probably get worse not
better
and so I think this Easter season it's
time for us to pause as a country to
pray and to ask God for his help his
mercy his blessing and I think it's
important that we turn to God as a
nation been we've turned our back on God
we have thrown his laws out the window
and they say they don't matter and our
politicians have done that people have
been idolatry God Hays idolatry more
than anything else and our country has
been consumed with idolatry and we've
sports becomes idols musicians become
idols our hobbies become our idols our
work becomes our idols and we have just
shoved God back into a closet and it's
like we don't we don't want him unless
as a crisis and this is a great time for
us as a people as a nation to turn to
God and call upon him and ask him for
help I wanted to ask you in one second
about the sort of correlation between
people doing bad things and God's
response to to us whether whether we can
actually see that in day to day life or
whether you know it's just incumbent on
us to seek God regardless of the
treatment that we're receiving from from
nature or from the world gonna get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about a quick way for you to save money
well being at home has there ever like
in human history been a better time to
avoid the post office like you may like
the post office but we're trying to
social distance here and carrying
packages to the post office does this
seem like a great use of either time or
money don't you wish that you were at
the post office right now you don't do
you this is why you meet stamps.com here
at daily wire we've been using stamps
calm since 2017 we are not wasting our
time and we're not standing in line
stamps.com brings all the services of
the US Postal Service directly to your
computer in the safety and comfort of
your own home office anywhere else you
are hunkering down right now simply use
your computer to print official US
postage 24/7 for any letter any package
any class of mail anywhere you want to
send it once your mail is ready just
leave it for the mail carrier schedule a
free package pick up or drop it in the
mailbox no human contact required which
is exactly what you're looking for
you'll get five cents off every
first-class stamp and up to 40% off US
Postal Service shipping rates and now in
addition to offering discounted USPS
rates stamps com also offers UPS
services with discounts of up to 62
percent plus with stamps com
you won't even have to pay UPS
residential surcharges this is a
no-brainer right now my listeners get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage ends digital
scale no long term commitment just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage type in Shapiro
that stamps comm enter Shapiro so let's
talk about one of the messages that you
just talked about Franklin and that is
the idea that we should be turning to
God during times of crisis that America
has turned her back on God I certainly
agree with you in terms of a lot of
moral standards that we've become
obviously a more secular atheistic
country I think I along with a lot of
other people in modern life pretty
uncomfortable with the idea that that
when bad things happen that that
represents God's punishment on us just
because there's not a one-to-one
correlation we see too often good things
happening to bad people and bad things
happening to good people so I was
wondering if maybe you could clarify on
that a little bit do you think that you
know we live in sort of a world where
pandemics happen and that's a punishment
from God or do you think that we live
more in a world where it's incumbent on
us to do the right thing regardless of
whether we receiving good or bad in our
own eyes not from God's eyes but from
from in our own eyes from from the world
around us well first of all God loves us
he cares for us and that's true if it's
someone else if someone can't remember
anything else we say on this program I
want them to remember that God loves you
and he does and we and bad things do
happen to good people and that we live
in a fallen broken world when Adam and
Eve the first couple God put him in a
perfect world now the Garden of Eden and
he didn't want bad things to happen but
he set down the rules and man chose to
disobey and Adam and Eve disobeyed God
and Israel result of that sin came into
the world and that's the fall of man and
so we're living in a broken world a
sinful world and it's it's that's where
we are but that's what Christ died for
our sins so that we don't have to pay
the debt of sin which is death he's
willing to give us eternal life if we're
willing to trust him but while we were
here on earth we're going to have pain
we're going to have sorrow we're going
to have death but we can have that hope
of eternal life with Christ one day if
we will turn and repent of our sins so
yes bad things happen and this
coronavirus whether that's God's
judgment how do I
no I mean I'm not he hasn't told me but
at the same time I think maybe God can
use this to get our attention as the
world not just a nation but the world to
look to him and to put our faith and
trust in him so I wanted to ask you
since where everybody is you know trying
to hunker down right now you've
obviously seen an enormous number of
inspirational actually talk about some
of them already the from from the folks
who work for Samaritan's Purse during
this crisis wondering if maybe you could
give me some instances of sort of
inspirational things that people are
doing right now to help out their fellow
man in the name of God well there was a
man in New York very wealthy fellow a
young guy and he saw us outside on
Central Park working me he just came
back can I help you volunteer he picked
up a shovel he started shoveling mulch
to help we had to have some walkways
because the grass was turning into mud
and he worked 13 hours shoveling and
again a very wealthy guy and he just
came out to volunteers people like that
that just come from different walks of
life these doctors and nurses that are
willing to put their life on the line to
save the life of other people it's
incredible and it's not just the doctors
and nurses most like this fellow who
young guy who had a lot of money but he
had some time on his hands and he was
bored sitting at his home he said can I
help it he picked up a shovel and that's
those type of people inspire me I'm just
so thankful and America has some
wonderful people good people and I think
we the media sometimes we focus too much
on these stars we've focused too much on
the Hollywood people whose lives for the
most part are empty and broken and have
very little to give but you take a young
guy like that it's just that's just an
example of one of many who have stood up
and have said Here I am use me
Sookie tell us a little bit more about
where Samaritan's Purse got started for
folks who don't know the background of
the organization at all well it was
started by a man by the name of Bob
Pierce back in 70 or excuse me 50 years
ago this year and his
he just wanted to help churches he
wanted to help people around the world
that were less fortunate and he ran it
for about the first 10 years and they
had leukemia and he asked if I would
take it over and at that time the
organization was very small he had three
secretaries and when I took over the
organization now the three secretaries
quit so for a while it was just it was
just me and God has brought an
incredible team of people over these
last 40 years that I've been running it
an incredible team of men and women and
I've learned one thing I've been I went
to business school one thing I learned
is hire people that are smarter than you
and at the end of the day they're gonna
make you look good so I've always tried
to find people that a lot smarter than
Franklin Graham and today that that's
there's paid off because big we get the
job done and it's not Franklin Graham
but it's just this incredible team of
people so I wanted to ask you about your
growing up so I met you mentioned
earlier obviously your father is the
most prominent evangelist of the last
century so what was it like growing up
in a home with Billy Graham well I think
the Billy Graham that the world saw on
television or the big stadiums was the
same Billy Graham we the children saw at
home there wasn't - Billy Graham's and
there wasn't my mother Ruth Graham there
wasn't a different person when the
cameras were turned off they were the
same and we saw that consistency in
their life and my father was a very
humble person if you approached him on
the sidewalk if he was walking down New
York's Fifth Avenue and somebody
recognized McCabe's old dr. Graham can I
shake your hand he would be kind of aw
shucks you want to shake my hand okay
well what's your name and his stand
there and talk to him and that's just
the way he was and so I'm very grateful
for that but he had a very deep faith he
believed the Bible and he'd be the first
one to say I don't understand it all but
I believe it all and he had just a very
simple faith and God gave him an
incredible you know ability to
communicate the Word of God what do you
think distinguish the message that he
was promulgating from some of the other
messages that were being proud
by different evangelists or or maybe the
sort of new wave of evangelists some of
them some of the televangelists you see
on TV what what he was such a
popularizer of the Bible what was
different between what he did and what
so many others have tried to do well I
mean I can't speak for for other people
my father certainly wouldn't want me to
my father just took the calling that God
gave him and he used that to the best of
his ability before he did anything he
would pray about it if he felt God
called him to go to England to preach or
go to Eastern Europe to preach go to
Russia to preach I he prayed about it
and if God laid something on his heart
he did it
and so I he would keep him here be
criticized I remember when he with the
Eastern Europe there are a lot of people
on the far-right accused him of being
used by the communists and I remember my
father smiling and saying well maybe I
want to use them and and he was just
very forceful very strong and he had a
great team of people around him that
supported him and helped him and he
certainly would want me to make sure
people understood it was the team it
wasn't just bit of grant but is the team
you mentioned earlier the phrase sort of
simple faith yeah there are a lot of
people in today's world who seem to
think that they are too sophisticated
for faith or who have been told that
that faith is unsophisticated that faith
requires you to ask no questions
that faith is easy and they find
themselves struggling with faith what
would you say to people who think that
faith is is too simple and and what
should the proper approach to faith be
what kind of questions are worthy of
asking well Ben I mean there are a lot
of skeptics out there and and they think
faith is a crutch and you know I don't
know what I can do to change their their
beliefs but you know then just take this
whole notion of evolution and there's
some how we started off as a tadpole and
got more and more and more sophisticated
as time passed over the millions of
years and all of a sudden we are who we
are today and there
millions of people that believe that and
I think it takes a lot more faith to
believe that because there's no evidence
whatsoever of where we came from
tadpoles or whatever some lured the
species but as a pilot I have a little
single-engine Piper Super Cub made in
1956 and I can park that out on the
runway I could tell you right now a
million years from now it's not going to
be a 747 they're engineers behind it
that develop it and put these things
together and there's a goes by a design
and the human body has a design and it's
unique when you look at our propulsion
system when you look at on electrical
system the pneumatic systems that our
our bodies have is incredibly designed
and there was a design about it just
didn't happen there's a creator and the
Bible says that God created the heaven
and the earth and everything in it and
been I just believe it but you have to
accept it by faith you just have to
believe it and I just believe it and
sometimes the people that have the most
sophistication the most expertise the
the higher the phd of learning sometimes
it's those people that are the hardest
ones to reach it has always seemed to me
that arguments like be the sort of
argument from design it's a response to
an argument that simply misses the point
of God which is that God can do whatever
he wants and that even if God wanted to
evolve you've evolved human beings from
a tadpole even if you believe that
evolution happens through a simply
natural selection and random you tation
why wouldn't God be able to design it
that way there's sort of this bizarre
disconnect where if there's a
naturalistic explanation therefore
nobody stands behind nature I've never
fully understood the idea that that if
nature has laws if nature has rules that
there there has to be there can't be any
designer for those laws or rules that
that somehow nature operating a certain
according to certain constructs is
somehow a disproof of God rather than a
proof of his presence and a mind at work
the world in which we live everything is
set into motion and our our universe is
set on a certain motion where's
many miles from the Sun if we were just
a few miles further or closer or we may
not be able to live on this planet how
we live in a very delicate sphere of
atmosphere and if you go five miles
straight up if you I don't know where
you live I'm sure you can have a vantage
point somewhere where you can look and
see five miles and stop that very far
and you go straight up five miles you're
not able to sustain life you can't
breathe at 25,000 feet we live in a
fragile envelope here on earth and we
need to we need to preserve it take care
of what God made it he created it and I
just have to believe him by faith Ben I
don't believe that somehow we just
appeared out of nowhere
God designed us and he's designed this
world and he designed this whole sphere
in which we live
and he put the stars in place and all of
that was a part of God's handiwork and I
just I just believe it and I know that
he loves us and he made us and he knows
everything about us individually he
knows our life he knows our problems and
the amazing thing is but we can talk to
him anytime anyplace anywhere I can talk
to God and I can and he wants to hear
our concerns and I think it's perfectly
fine with God for us to call him in the
middle of the night he's not asleep he's
not some God that has to have sleep he's
there just call his name he's there and
and he will hear if we put our faith and
trust in His Son Jesus Christ he's going
to hear us there is no other the body
jesus said I'm the way the truth and the
life no man comes to the Father but by
me there's not multiple roads to God
there's only one path to God and that
goes through the cross because Jesus is
the only one in history to take the sins
of mankind and no other person ever
claimed to say I took your sins I died
in your place nobody nobody's ever
claimed that only one that's Jesus
Christ he said I took your sins and I
died in your place and I laid my life
down and I took it back
again and he's alive in his life forever
and the Bible says he's coming back
and I believe that could be soon
something that is eminently true and has
been proved true over the course of the
last several decades is that the decline
in Church in the United States that the
rise in secularism has had some pretty
dire social effects I want to talk about
with that with you in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that
you're spending an awful lot of time
online right now because you can't go
outside literally you cannot so if
you're a hacker this is your paradise
because you can just hack anybody people
are putting their credit card
information online unprotected don't be
one of the dupes instead go get a VPN
from Express at VPN expressvpn will give
you the best online protection possible
I've been talking about expressvpn on my
show for so long you already know why
encrypting your network data is
important some of you still have not
acted now is the time you might be
thinking security threats don't affect
you personally but not using expressvpn
that's like leaving your front door
unlocked every time you go out so
nothing might happen for years when a
break-in does happen it's not gonna be
great one of the easiest ways to secure
your internet data is with expressvpn
click one button on your computer or
smartphone and you are now protected so
here's the only question why haven't you
gotten expressvpn yet visit my special
link right now expressvpn calm /ban get
an extra three months of expressvpn for
free protect your internet today with
the VPN I trust to keep my own data safe
that's expressvpn comm slash Ben I'm on
the internet all the time and I use
Express VPN you should too expressvpn
comm slash Ben Franklin we look at the
rise of secularism and non-affiliated
is the number one group of Millennials
bro we're watching younger people
basically rejecting religion wholesale
we're seeing organized religion in
decline by statistics why do you think
that is particularly given the fact that
after several decades of an increasingly
secular America it is obvious that there
are pretty dire social effects to to
exactly that sort of secularization
particularly in in some of the more
hard-hit Rust Belt areas that when when
churches disappear so does the social
fabric and we've seen opioid epidemic
sand and broken lives we've seen
epidemics of suicide disconnection well
why does secular it why is secularism
been on the rise despite the fact that
there has been such obvious evidence of
dire consequences
well secularism first of all let's go
back to what talk about the decline of
the the church
I'm not sure the church is in decline I
think there are some mainline
denominations that quit preaching the
Bible for some time and people just quit
attending those churches what you see is
a rise of bible teaching churches where
pastors just get up in the open up the
bible say louis read today what God's
Word says and they start teaching the
Bible those churches are full they're
packed people are hungry today they want
to know the Word of God and secularism
is it gives a license for people to live
is just about any kind of wicked life
they want to without any consequences
and of course that's very attractive and
a lot of people go that direction and
say oh this is gonna be fun this is
going to be great but there's emptiness
and you're right the suicide rate the is
just incredible how the problems of
secularism break cause it doesn't give
answers it gives them this license to be
free but at the end of the day they're
not free and they're their slaves to sin
and they want to be free they want
answers they're searching and looking
for something better and they're not
finding and I want people to know that
what they're searching for is God and if
they put their trust in him he'll take
that broken life and he'll put it
together just like it did mine and you
know use you and he'll forgive you and
cleanse you and give you the hope for
the morning hope for the next day and
how important we need today we need that
hope for the next day
major media in the United States have
have basically blamed evangelicals for
getting involved in politics they're
very upset with religious people being
involved in politics they say that this
is religious theocracy that seems to me
that it's precisely the opposite of what
actually happened what actually happened
is that there was a fairly wide social
consensus on a wide variety of issues
and that the secular left in the 1960s
basically broke those down and
evangelical Christians like religious
people of all stripes basically stood up
on their hind legs and said well no you
don't get to discard those social
consensus the consensus says without any
sort of evidence when do you think it
becomes incumbent on religious people to
get involved in politics under one
circumstance do you think
religious people shouldn't be involved
in politics and and how should they be
involved in politics well first of all
in in 2016 I went to every state Capitol
held a prayer rally on the Capitol Steps
I thought if I would have a few hundred
join me in prayer that would be
important because I felt our country was
in trouble and we needed to pray instead
of hundreds it was thousands many ten
and some places tens of thousands of
people who showed up on the Capitol
Steps to pray and they weren't there to
hear me speak that they were there to
pray for our nation and so these were
people that cared for our country that
prayed I never endorsed a person in the
last election and I just encouraged
people to pray the way they felt God was
leading them to vote I encourage people
to vote and then I also encourage
Christians to run for office
we need the Christian voice in state
politics in the Statehouse we need them
in the local politics we need them
school board's how important school
boards are and if we could have
Christians on school boards and have
their voice heard how important that
would be and so I encourage Christians
to not only to vote but to get involved
politically because of the you know the
gays and lesbians have have their
candidates Muslims have their candidates
so many people have their candidates and
I think it's important for Christians to
have candidates out there that they can
run and win and we need the Christian
voice this is America this is democracy
and we we certainly have the right to
have a voice at the table so that's kind
of what we're doing Ben we encourage
people to vote again I don't try to tell
people how to vote I'm a conservative
I have conservative values just and not
only politically but spiritually I have
conservative values and but I think we
as conservatives have a right to be
heard and they have a right to vote and
to be part of the process how should
Christians think about the separation of
church and state every time Christians
get involved in politics their
accusations that they're trying to
establish a Christian theocracy that
this is The Handmaid's Tale or something
like that
how should the house for Christians
think about their involvement in
politics while respecting the boundaries
between church and state well I mean I
think we don't compromise
I think there's part of the problem
we've had is Christians have compromised
we shouldn't compromise we should hold
to what the Bible teaches and hold to
those standards and if we if we have a
majority I think we have an opportunity
to to to pass some good laws maybe in
this country there so we have that right
to be a voice and you know if you take a
hundred years ago the political leaders
in the communities were the pastor's if
your house burned down and you were your
family was desolate you went to the
local church and the pastor would find
somebody in the community that would
take you in they would clothe they would
feed you they would care for you but the
government has taken those type of
social services upon themselves and they
don't do nearly as good as the churches
used to do it and what happened the
church is kind of okay but we'll just
let the government do that then and we
have slowly backed up and backed up and
let the government take more and more
and more control of society and they're
not doing a better job at it they're
doing an inferior job not better with a
lot of the problems that we face today
were handled at the local level it was
done with compassion with love and with
the interest of the people that they
were helping the day is just clinical
and the government just writes out a
check and thinks that will solve it but
the problems of this world need more
than just a check it needs people one on
one interaction people that care people
that are willing to let their voice be
heard of people that are willing to to
go into a community and and and make a
difference with your life I invested in
that community and make a difference so
Franklin obviously we live in an
incredibly vitriolic time we've taken an
enormous amount of abuse for expressing
support for president Trump and some of
the things that he's done as president
of the United States how do you rate his
his overall performance as president
well I I support the president he's our
president but we don't have another
present he's
he's the only one we got and he needs
our prayers he's had a very difficult
when he ran in 2016
most of the Republicans were against him
I'm talking about Republican leadership
now of course the Democrats were against
him and and he somehow he won the
election and people asked me how did he
do it I think it was God but for some
reason I think God just just picked
Donald J Trump and you say well he's
flawed he's a sinful person he's though
this or that well we're all flawed and
we're all sinful but somehow God chose
him to be the president at this
particular time in history and I think
he's done an incredible job no question
the the economy is the best it's ever
been we're in the middle of the
coronavirus aisle we've got a lot of
people out of work right now but this is
temporary and the economy is still very
strong and I think the president has
done an incredible job with the
coronavirus I've just shudder to think
if someone else was surprised this time
you know the mess that we would be in
but he's does a he knows how to get
people working and he's got the industry
right now General Motors and people like
that building ventilators he put the
hospital ships in New York in California
where these the the opposition said it
would take him six weeks to do it he did
in one week he knows how to he knows how
to push buttons and make things happen
and he is the commander in chief and so
I certainly give him a plus plus so
there was a lot of controversy obviously
in 2016 specifically surrounding
president Trump's character his personal
character there are a lot of people
including me who are very critical of a
lot of his conduct I've continued to to
do what I call the sort of good Trump
bad Trump model overall I'm the
supporter of the president at this point
I would support his reelection but at
the same time I'm not I'm not willing to
let him get away with with sort of some
of the things that he says and does and
they make me deeply uncomfortable how
how should religious people deal with
the fact that you mentioned he's a
flawed character we're all flawed
characters but how should religious
people specifically deal with sort of
the character flaws that are evident in
in President Trump without necessarily
covering for
even if they are supporters well a lot
of the accusation been of the president
in his lifestyle 20 years ago and he's
not the same person he was 20 years ago
neither you and neither am i he's
changed and now he tweets and he will
say things that that a lot of people
cringe at but but he's attacked every
day by the media every single day and
that is his one opportunity to fight
back it's Twitter is his newspaper and
he doesn't have to get filtered by
somebody Inco directly to the American
people and it's worked for him now the
American people are behind the President
and I don't allow the polls will show
well Biden is ahead by two points or you
know so what else may be ahead by two
points I don't believe in that by a
second I think if you had the the
election today he would win too
overwhelming hands-down there's there's
just he's an incredible person and I
think people I have trust and confidence
in him and so again I don't agree with
everything he says or does but at the
same time he is the president and we
just have to trust him and back him and
sub and help him all weekend well in one
second I want to ask you about an
article that now seems forever ago from
the December 2019 issue of Christianity
today which apparently you know
obviously claim that President Trump
should be removed from office but if you
want to hear it Franklin Graham talked
about that article about Christianity
today and about the legacy of that
magazine you have to be subscribed over
at daily we're now calm so head on over
to daily we're calm and subscribe well
Franklin Graham thank you so much for
stopping by the show I really appreciate
and thanks for all the amazing work
Samaritan's Purse is doing for people
all over the world really thank you sir
thank you god bless
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
directed by Mike Joyner and produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring associate producer Katie Swinton
our guests are booked by Kaitlyn Maynard
post-production is supervised by Alex's
and Garo editing is by Jim nickel audio
is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup
is by NECA Geneva title graphics are by
Cynthia Angulo the venture Pierrot shows
Sunday special is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
[Music]